hey there it's me again one of the
toughest parts about being an eighty
five percenter is constantly being broke
now when you were in college you'd great
excuses to call home for money mom I
need more money for books mom I need
some money for food mom I need money for
a giant Scarface poster but when you
move home whether or not you're
officially paying rent you're gonna end
up paying one way or another
there you go re are you using tap water
no I gotten out of the hose bottled and
filtered water only I told you you're
gonna have to start over I'm pouring
water onto dirt don't you think it's
gonna get dirty when it hits dirt how
much money if I made so far I took on
the garbage I wash dad's car I mowed the
lawn and I walk a dog eight dollars how
am I supposed to take a girl out on
eight dollars well do some more chores
huh free ride here this isn't Buckingham
Palace do I look like a queen a gnome
seven I got two dollars a chore have you
heard of inflation now listen sweetheart
I love you I I do okay but to be honest
your friend rob here would do half the
chores for some KFC bites oh yeah think
about it oh my god sunday edition ruined
I didn't do that oh really I found it
under soaking wet chamois and it reached
at Turtle Wax guilty I'm gonna deduct a
buck for that one although the car does
look immaculate otherwise I'd withhold a
full to what I need my sunday funnies
Michael what's the matter don't like the
sound of your old man laughing honey
where's that hair dryer Michael come
down to the basement I'm in your room
what do you want any money right yes I
do do do give you litter box be a dear
and clean it that's what that smell has
been five bucks yeah I gotta get out of
here Michael you need to get out of
there you gotta do something become a
traffic cop live under a bridge well
don't live under a bridge but but you
need to get out of there do something do
to you still living at home with your
parents we're here to help into the
comedy central growing up and getting
out contest you could win read for a
year presented by KFC original recipe
bites bite-sized chicken is all
on